- And of course what it
all clarified was the fact
that the Antifa activists
have a very clear policy
which is that they want
to provoke the police
or need any law enforcement
into something they
can pretend is an act of
violence that they can catch
on camera and use
as an explanation
for the allegedly fascists
nature of the American state.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
this is the Rubin Report.
Joining me today is a
best-selling author,
political pundit
and now American cultural
expert Douglas Murray.
Douglas welcome to
the Rubin Report.
- It's a great pleasure
to be back with you, Dave
- Do you consider yourself
an American cultural expert
now that you spent, how long?
About two months traversing
our great country
seeing cities burn and going
to joyous rallies and
everything in between.
Are you a cultural
expert of Americana now?
- If I am, then there's hundreds
of millions of others as well.
And it certainly does
feel like that sometimes.
I do notice that many
millions of cultural experts
on America don't bother
going there at all
and don't bother
traveling around.
But yeah, I mean I spent a
very very interesting period
ahead of the
election, as you know
traveling all
around your country
to the extent that
you can in these days
went across about
six or seven states
and was there right up until
just after the election.
I spent the election
in Washington DC.
- Yeah so I thought you'd
be the right guy to talk
to for my post Thanksgiving show
because I thought we could
get away a little bit
from like the minutia
of American politics
but I think getting
your perspective
as an outsider that
spent so much time here
and that has a
cohesive worldview.
So I thought we'd
start by saying
so when you were here
about six weeks ago or so
we actually went
out to lunch one day
and we were just heading back.
We were heading back to my place
and we saw a Trump
rally in Beverly Hills.
We did not know that
there was a Trump rally
but we got out of the
car and we thought,
all right let's do
a little exploration
and see what's what.
I think at this point my
audience knows my take on it.
What was your take
on that rally?
And then subsequently
you went to a bunch
of others and got
to see some stuff.
- Yes I mean I
wanted to get a sense
of where America was
ahead of the election.
I was writing from multiple
states from New York
Long Island, to
California, to Oregon
to Atlanta Georgia, Pensacola
Florida, Washington DC.
I did quite a good round.
And one of the purposes
of it really was to
try to get a sense of the
temperature in America
at the moment.
I haven't been in the country
for a couple of years,
I've traveled there
a lot in my life
but I noticed quite a lot
of things that seemed new to
me or at least worse to me.
And as for that
particular day, I mean
that was an interesting
thing, wasn't it?
Because thought, well, LA was
an unlikely place to stumble
across a pro-Trump rally.
I thought it was
very good natured
and diverse to use the most
important word of the era.
- Of course
- And I suppose the other
thing that struck me
was something else
that I noticed
in other places
across my travels
which was that I actually
predicted ahead of the election.
I didn't know how
it was gonna go
but I did say ahead of the
election that I thought
that there was a
quiet Trump vote.
Well, I might even say an
embarrassed Trump vote to some
was likely to signify
something at the polls.
And one of the things was
it was only one of the
examples, but was yes, the fact
that I think that day
about what about one
at one in every two
cars I'd have thought
was beeping support
for that rally in LA.
And I thought that was striking.
And I found a certain
amount of other that sort of
quiet Trump voter in California.
So yeah it was one sort
of peak on example,
of something that was
definitely going on.
- Was it sort of
doubly surprising?
' Cause as someone that's a
media creature and you know
how the media operates
and everything else,
to see it on the ground
and just how sort
of different it was.
I mean, you said
the diversity word
but I mean truly they
were blacks for Trump
and Asians for Trump
and Jews for Trump
and Christians were
Trump and gays for Trump.
Did that still shock you,
even though maybe you know
that the media
doesn't report on this
in the most totally honest way?
- No I'm quite hard to
shock and it can be done
but it takes an
awful lot of effort.
And I know I had assumed
that a lot of people
were finding their own
way for themselves.
My own experience in
the last few years
in multiple countries has been
that there are things
that the media say
and they bang on at
and they still don't.
impact individuals who can
come to their own decisions
particularly in our era
where they can find their own
sources of information
and find their own groups
of like-minded people and see
through certain
myths that are told.
So I wasn't surprised at that
the rally in Pensacola
Florida, I went to it
which is a much bigger
affair, of course
thousands and
thousands of people.
One of many things that
struck me was the good
naturedness of the crowd.
And of course that is something
which doesn't come across
in almost any press coverage
which presents the
president's rallies
as being rather
hate-filled affairs
and irrespective of whatever
he says from the podium.
And I can't deny it.
I mean being a
member of the press
when he starts to sort of point
when he pointed to
the press gallery
and started saying
that the lying press
and everyone started
booing, I suppose
it's still part of my
hackles go up at that.
But I was there as a
member of the audience.
I signed up as an attendee and
was right in the heart of it,
they are meeting
notes, clearly a member
of the press and introducing
myself as a journalist
and was treated
only with courtesy
and kindness by the attendees.
So there was no sort
of unpleasant undertone
or anything like that.
- Yeah so you left Los Angeles.
I said goodbye to
you and you said,
"I'm going to Portland."
And I said,
" Why are you
going to Portland?"
And I think you said,
"I need to see it for myself."
So you went up to Portland,
what do you see up in Portland?
- I slightly shot my bolt on
this because I wrote a piece
for one of the papers saying
California is a failed state
and then I went to Oregon.
(chuckles)
- Yeah.
- Yeah Portland is,
some people say to me,
why do you need to go and
see this stuff for yourself?
And I just think it's an
instinctive curiosity I have.
And I also, even when
it is exactly what you
think it is going to be,
it's still interesting.
Portland Oregon was
exactly what I feared
it would be but a bit worse.
I was horrified by the
immiseration of the city,
the total destruction
of all public monuments
and public buildings, the
shuffling up of shops,
intimidation of the citizenry,
the demoralization
of the citizenry, a
homelessness problem
which makes even
California's look minimal.
And the fact that the city
is basically been given
over to an immiserated
lawlessness
I went with Antifa several
nights in a row to,
pardon the language, a
fuck gentrification protest
which was my first.
And...
- Yeah that was your first one?
- Yeah, it was, yes.
I've hitherto always
avoided the temptation
I quite like
gentrification, actually.
I think that the house
is being made nicer
and neighborhood being
smarter is no bad thing
but old fashioned view,
certainly not the view
of Antifa in Portland
who sectioned off
some of the streets
and went through them in
the middle of the night
screaming at the citizens
and the house owners
telling them they were
all on stolen land.
This included many black
families, by the way
shouting at these black
families, white families,
families of every
background, shouting at them
they were on stolen
land and should get out.
- Were you worried
for your own safety?
I mean, you were
out there with them.
I mean, people know who you are.
- Yes I was lucky enough
in the era of mask wearing
you can cover almost the
entire face lawfully,
indeed almost compulsively.
And I was, I mean, I've
been in worse places
in war zones where there's
more lawlessness than that
but it was not an a
pleasant situation to be
in a what is nominally
a first world city?
The second night, I went
with them to the protest
to the ice facility where,
which was a bit hairier
because they were
assaulting the, so its one
of the very few federal
buildings in the area.
They play a game of cat and
mouse with law enforcement
they get closer and closer
to the front of the building.
Their aim in the past has been
to barricade in the buildings
put burning dumpster
trucks in front of them
and then kill the people
inside by burning them alive.
So that's their modus operandi.
So you can understand why the
ICE officers don't want that.
And they get within a
certain closeness to the door
and then the officers break
out and there was firing
tear, gas, pepper bullets
and all that and people
were setting fire to things
in the street and
that was unpleasant.
Yes, it got, you know,
shoot out of an alleyway
by federal officers with a
bunch of other Antifa with me
and the officers at
gunpoint told us please
to move out of the alleyway
and it was unpleasant.
But I have to say that
considering the situation
I thought the officer's whereas
as decent and reasonable
and efficient in their duties
as they could possibly be.
And of course what it all
clarified was the fact
that the Antifa activists
have a very clear policy
which is that they want
to provoke the police
or need any law enforcement
into something they
can pretend is an act
of violence that they
can catch on camera
and use as an explanation
for the allegedly fascist
nature of the American state.
It was very interesting to
see these activists up close.
I thought they were all
reprehensible people.
I thought they were
clearly mentally
in a very unstable place.
I thought that furthermore
on election night
in Washington, DC
when I saw Antifa
gathering in the doorways
just outside the North
lawn of the White House
the world's press were
pointing their cameras
at the White House.
And beside them underneath
some of the doorways
I saw what was clearly Antifa
gathering because
they were changing
into clothes so that they
couldn't be recognized
by CCTV cameras went
over to film this
'cause it was clear that
this was what was going on
and they became very
violent, very fast.
And they are thugs they
are a paramilitary group.
They have no place
in a democracy
it's to America's shame that
they've been allowed to do
what they have been doing.
They threatened to
kill journalists.
They had graffitied "kill
Andy Ngo" mutual friend
and a journalist and
reporter in Portland, Oregon.
They had graffitied calls to
murder him across the city.
The fact that they can then
intimidate a journalist
from abroad who even has the
tenacity to try to capture them
on the video camera or
look at what they're doing
is very bad.
Is an embarrassment
from America.
I think the whole
thing's an embarrassment.
- Did you get a sense that
when you're on the ground
with them that
there is a leader?
Because this is what Joe Biden
described Antifa as an idea
and partly what I
think it seems to be is
that there's no sort of known
leader sort of by design
but when you're out there
with these groups, DC Portland
wherever you are,
could you sense like,
Oh somebody is
actually in charge
or is it just like
this roving gang?
Yeah
- No, of course they
have a leadership.
Andy Ngo's forthcoming book
will reveal a lot about this
but yeah, of course
they have a leadership.
They don't gather like
moisture or something.
I mean, it's a, they
are brought together.
They are organized.
They advertise within
their own groups
what they're going to do
and when and what
their actions are.
They tell people what to bring
or what not to bring, what
to say and what not to say
what to chant and
what not to chant.
And yeah, I mean they
do the whole thing.
They're an organized group.
And by the way, one of the most
haunting things for me was,
among other things I
interviewed lots of people
on my travels including black
police officers in Oregon,
who I think were
some of the most,
the bravest most remarkable
and I thought restrained
people I've ever met.
But one of the conversations
that haunted me even more
than that, was speaking to
an owner of a restaurant in,
a cafe in Portland who
had just recently had
just the day before had had
bullets live ammunition bullets
fired through the
windows of his business
because it seemed
because he has photos
on the wall of first responders,
a woman soldier, a US soldier,
a man in fireman's uniform.
And this apparently makes him a
a representative of the
fascistic American state
thus live ammunition is fired
by Antifa BLM activists
through his business.
By the way, he is a black
American, a very proud patriot.
And he said to me, actually,
we talked about this.
I said to him, what
do you think of the
of the them
presidential contender
Joe Biden's claim that
it's just an idea.
And he pointed to the
bullet holes in his business
his windows, and he said,
" But an idea doesn't
fire bullets."
- I mean that's it.
- So, yeah.
- So what was your
main takeaway?
Now that now that
you've left our shores
you got to see sort of the
bipolar nature of America.
We're still in this sort of
election limbo at the moment,
millions of people not
celebrate Thanksgiving
with their families
because of COVID and
everything else, or the lock
I should say the lockdowns
more than COVID specifically.
What's your diagnosis of
of what we're
going through here?
- Oh, I think you're
in real trouble.
I think you're in real trouble.
All countries are
to some extent.
I mean, we all have
the COVID layer on top
of everything else
and the financial catastrophe
that it constitutes
my own country has got to find
a way to pay for something
like 210 billion pounds
spent so far this year
in the COVID era.
These sorts of sums very
hard to recoup in taxation
without crippling our
economy afterwards.
We've all got a lot of trouble
and we have this
very testing year.
We're all in, still
in with lock downs
and inability to
see our loved ones
because of a virus
that is serious.
But I think in my own estimation
not as bad as the thing we
thought it was at the outset
and there will be a long period
of people arguing over the
whether we overreacted
or not with this virus
but all of these things in a way
seem to reveal underlying
problems in a society as well.
I've been struck now, I say that
in my own country there was
a period of political unity
at the beginning
of the current era.
We unified as a country
around health service
our prime minister,
specifically around the queen.
And it was a very
moving thing actually
because we'd said
for years in Britain
we'd had no societal trust
and no points of unity.
And actually, I thought
we did have some
we've lost some of it
since perhaps inevitably
but we did have stores
of trust and unity.
The one country in
the world I know of
where that just didn't
last a second was America
because of the nature
of the Trump presidency
because of its divisiveness
because of the era
that America was in
and because it was
an election year
you just had no period of unity.
And I was struck state by state.
Some States life was going
on for better or worse
as if the COVID
Coronavirus didn't exist.
And other States
you were told off
if you weren't wearing
your mask in the street.
So and it seemed to be
along political lines
and I can appreciate that it is,
but I also lament that in a way
because it would be good
if America could even
have a pandemic, but
reminded Americans
that they're in it
together in some way.
And you just, you
can't even do that.
And may I add one other thing?
The one that worries me most
now about your country is this.
I think the worry people had
which is the people in America
imbibing different information
streams is a kiddie worry
compared to the real
one you've now got.
The real one you've now got is
you don't any longer
agree as a nation
on what you just saw,
that is terrifying.
- So...
- That is absolutely terrible.
- I've been describing
that as the reality war
that that is this isn't
about the cultural battle
this isn't about the
political battle.
Those are, those are battles.
Those are sort of small
battles, but it's all framed
by the reality war,
which is nobody agrees.
And even in we're
holding this interview
for just two or three days
the amount of stuff
that could change
in two or three
days even is crazy.
But you know, when
you mention the sort
of the way we do lock
downs, I'm reminded
we went out for lunch
a different day,
and we were sitting
in that little strip mall
area where we ordered
from one restaurant and
you wanted a cup of coffee
or you wanted a
cappuccino or something
but we were sitting outside
a Starbucks, which was closed
but they told us we
couldn't get coffee
because Starbucks
owns the strip mall
and wouldn't allow
them to serve coffee
even though the
Starbucks was closed.
Like, that's the level of
insanity that we're dealing with
that at a micro level.
- Well, it's a great
extent the Corona era
has allowed lots of bossy people
to do the stuff
they like the most.
(chuckles)
I mean, there are some
people who love to,
you can notice it in certain
establishments that are open
there are certain people
who just won't do things
and you ask them why.
And they say, 'cause
of Corona and even
there are quite a
lot of establishment
so I think it was John
Cleese who said famously
after doing "Fawlty Towers"
that the definition
of a bad hotel
or restaurant was
one run entirely
for the comfort of the staff.
And there are quite a lot
of establishments, I think
unwisely for that
future, which have,
I mean airlines and
lots of other things
which are doing lots of things
that are quite comfortable
for the staff
but make things extra
unpleasant for the clientele.
But no the bigger
problem you have is
you just can't
agree on anything.
You didn't agree on the virus
and didn't agree on
any response to it.
And now we have absolutely
ground zero of this problem.
Can I by the way
say very quickly?
- Yeah
- There's only one other thing
of similar gravity I've seen
in a developed democracy
which is a very small
thing that a lot of people
didn't take any
notice of at the time.
But it's two years ago in a
town called Chemnitz in Germany
there was a video
released by actually
as it happens an Antifa account
that had just cropped up
could well have been a
disinformation account
nobody quite knows.
It showed some
German looking men
and some migrant looking men.
And the account said that
it was a migrant hunt
that was happening.
It was a very serious thing.
They'd been a stabbing
and by a bio migrant
of a local only a
few days earlier
tensions in the
area were very high.
This video was released
by an anonymous account.
And by hours after the
release of the video,
the German Chancellor
Angela Merkel said publicly,
" We cannot allow this
the hunting of human
beings in Germany.
The reason I tell you this
story is because of this
the head of the Domestic
Intelligence Service
in Germany said publicly,
" No, it doesn't show that."
Hans-Georg Maaßen the man
who was the most important,
the head of the Domestic
Intelligence Service
disagreed with the Chancellor.
He said,
" No, it's not that."
Now there's a dispute
he was actually was dismissed
from his post that week
- Wow
- Now but exactly.
I wrote about at
the time I said,
look irrespective of
the details or exactly
what it is that's going on,
this should be a
real warning moment
because we haven't had,
we've had a case
where people disagree
about how you
interpret documents
or sources and all
sorts of things.
But for the Chancellor
and the Head
of the Intelligence
Service to disagree
over a piece of footage
is very, very worrying.
Then we come to 2020 in America.
More than eight out of 10
Trump voters in the last poll
I saw believe Donald
Trump won the election.
And obviously Joe Biden's
voters believe he won.
This seems to me a very
perilous moment for democracy.
It's what I just described in
cabinets on a national level
you saw the same thing
and you've come away with
different conclusions.
- What do you think would
be a responsible way
for the media to
talk about this then?
'Cause one of the things
I've been trying to do
for the last couple of
weeks here is I'm saying,
look I don't know
exactly what happened.
I don't think
anyone really knows.
I do know that at about
midnight Pacific time here
that about eight States
that Trump had healthy leads
in all stopped voting
at the same exact time.
I'm not saying Trump won
Now it's going to
go to the courts
and there's all sorts
of things happening
but I've at least
been trying to talk
about it respectfully, right.
So that it allows people to
say, okay let the process work.
And then at the end, if
it comes out that yes
did I want Trump win to win?
Yes but if the courts
look at everything
and he doesn't
win then so be it.
But I think what a lot
of people are frustrated
that that eight out of
10, you just referenced,
I think what they're seeing is
that the media won't even
let you talk about it.
And that if you talk about it
you're gonna be put on a list
and you're gonna be labeled
a conspiracy theorist
and you're gonna get
booted from social media
and the rest of it.
And that strikes me
as more of a problem
maybe then what actually
happened at some level.
- Well no, I disagree with that.
I mean, I think the
biggest problem is
if the president doesn't
leave the White House
and he's lost, I mean this
is the biggest problem.
- Oh, well of course
that if we get there
and he has actually lost and
he doesn't leave of course.
- I mean, you know,
look I'm sympathetic
to much of your argument on this
and your point of view
on this but I mean the
And I'm by the way
I'm particularly
irate about the fact
that there were so many
Democrats who spent four years
claiming that the
American voting system
had been fundamentally
undermined
and indeed that the Russians
had stolen the 2016 election
something for which they
never showed us any evidence
but they asserted anyway.
- Nancy Pelosi
literally said that
that it was an illegitimate
election, I mean, its yeah
- I'm irate about that.
I was irate about
it for four years.
I'm irate about the fact that
these same people now pretend
that there is no such thing
as voter fraud in America.
However, the owners at this
stage is on Donald Trump
and his legal team to prove
that he won the election.
Now I have to say, I've paid
fairly close attention to this.
As I say, first of all may I
say, the thing of going to bed
and the result being
different when you wake up
is not unheard of in elections.
I mean in the Brexit vote,
lots of people went
to bed thinking that
that Britain was going to
remain in the European Union
I remember it very clearly.
And of course then suddenly
the results from Sunderland
and elsewhere in the North
of England came through
and whoosh we were out
and the same people woke
up the next morning amazed
but that's what happens
sometimes in elections.
I do think that Donald
Trump is behaving
reprehensibly at the moment.
I think that frankly,
I am very open for any
and all explanations
of voter fraud
as it is going on in
America as it has gone on.
I think whoever is president
on January the 20th rather
as a point of absolute
urgency should put together
a bipartisan nonpartisan
cross partisan team
to look into voter
fraud, specifically
mail-in voter fraud in the
United States of America.
You cannot have another
election after this one
which would be a third
in a row where people
didn't believe the
results if they lost.
So it seems to me to be
real point of urgency this
but on election night,
when Donald Trump came out
in the early hours of
the morning and said
"I believe we've already won.
"We've won as far
as I'm concerned,"
he said.
I gasped, I gasped.
I thought, oh hell.
And there's several
things about that.
One is you better, if
you're the Trump team
you better provide really
good proof, fast about that.
And frankly what
they've provided
is not good enough proof yet.
They have been providing
some things that sound to me
like they are
conspiracy theories
unless they've got a
lot of stuff to come.
I hope for their sake, they've
got a lot of stuff to come
or there are a
lot of reputations
that are being
trashed all the time
(mumbles)
- Well, that's what
I said from B one.
It's like Sidney Powell.
She's either self-immolating
in front of us
or she's about to break
the greatest story
in the history of modern times.
It's one or the other, right?
- Yeah and I suspect
it's the first.
And I think the same
with Rudy Giuliani.
You just can't give
press conferences talking
about dead Venezuelan leaders
and think that the citizenry
should, I mean, it's not just
that you shouldn't treat
the citizenry stupidly,
you should not miss the
lead people's belief
in the most fundamental
thing in our nations
which is that we vote
and some people win and
some people lose them
and you know who's
lost and who's won.
This is a really
dangerous thing.
This is a dangerous
element to be playing with.
And I worry deeply about
the consequences of this.
But another thing to
point out about this is,
that I mean, everyone
has to lose sometimes
I remember Michael
Barone saying this
to some conservative gathering
I once sat many years ago.
I think when Obama won,
Michael Barone said, you know
you have to lose some times.
The evidence so far seems to
be that the Republican nominee
for the presidency
lost this time.
Now here's the kicker
if I may say so
For four years,
one of the questions has been
why has Donald Trump
not been able to ...
Now, there have been some
very remarkable people
who have worked for him.
And I wouldn't do
that in any of them.
I'm thinking of people like,
I think Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo, Elliott
Abrams and others
some very very
serious particular
foreign policy figures
who have worked for him
and I deeply admire,
but there has been a question
throughout the Trump presidency.
Why can he not appear to get
more people working with him
more experienced people
working for him, older hands
more trusted figures, some
non-family would be nice
and so on and so forth.
What is the explanation?
And it's one of those
political questions
that ends up answering itself.
It's because everyone worried
that at the end of the run,
he would pull some
crap like this.
That was why, that was why
I spoke to a lot of people
in recent years in America
and said to them and
American friends and said,
would you consider
taking this post?
Why don't you consider
taking that role?
And I always noticed that
some of them early on
and I would say, he's
got four years in office.
It's not nothing to be
whatever position
was being discussed.
And I noticed always
this reticence,
I think Neil Ferguson
on your show said that
there was always this risk
that Trump was
gonna do something
or come down in a way
that was a scandal
of not any Nixonian proportions
but it would make
Nixon look like,
as sort of a tea party,
no tea party means
something else I
didn't mean anyway
- That means something else does
Not a British tea but well
- Yeah yeah.
- A British tea
party of another turn
- A cake walk, a cake walk, a
cake walk, I think that, yeah.
- Cakewalk, yeah
- And I think that
what we're seeing
at the moment may be the
answer to that question.
I have seen it once
else in politics
in European continental
politics with a much
more minor political figure
who the same question was
why can't people
cohere around him?
Why don't people trust him?
And in the end, the
answer answered itself
because he was
going to in the end
pull the crazy crappy he pulled,
And I just, I think that unless
the Trump team can
very very swiftly
provide evidence that is
very good and persuasive,
they are playing
with an element that they
should not be playing with.
And I think it will
it will deeply diminish
the Republican Party
if it allows it to go on, it
will diminish conservatives.
It will diminish the
millions and millions
of decent American
voters who were trying to
send a very distinct
message in 2016
who were reviled for four
years, insulted for four years
called every imaginable
name in for four years
it will further demoralize
them and weaken them.
I hope if he has something,
it comes out fast.
- Yeah by the way,
Douglas, you know
while I'm obviously
sympathetic to the campaign
and I wanted him to win, I'm
completely with you on that.
It's like if there
isn't anything there
and they've truly
done something here
that was to destroy the system
or completely erode
trust or anything else,
yeah then it's almost
the most dangerous thing.
Well, I guess it would be the
second, most dangerous thing
compared to actually
rigging the election.
So we'll find out over
the next couple of weeks.
- If they have
if you Democrats did
actually rig the election
then it is indeed it is
the most appalling crime
against American democracy.
And there should be such
a thorough investigation
and so many people
going to prison.
It would be the scandal
of our lifetimes.
But if it isn't the case,
if it isn't the case
then it is also a great scandal
because you cannot lie to
the citizen about this.
I'm very open to the
argument of four years ago
Hillary Clinton didn't
really admit that
she lost the election and
spent years pretending she
had only lost election
because of the Russians
and something to do
with a box on Facebook.
Look, I thought that
was contemptible.
I think Hillary
Clinton was again
playing with fire to do
her the one piece of credit
that one can do.
At least she didn't actually
tunnel into the Oval Office
and barricade herself in it
after the election in 2016.
It's the one thing Hillary
Clinton has going for her
at the moment.
- Yeah that is the
one thing I suppose
I thought maybe we could
shift this a little bit
to the UK and kind of talk
about maybe some parallels
or just complete differences
to what you guys have going on.
So I've been talking about
this for a long time,
but sort of that all
everything we've discussed
here has sort of led
to the destruction of
liberalism in the United States
that we don't really
have many liberals left.
I would say the few
we have actually
at this point are
basically conservatives.
You guys have a different
version of that right?
Like, do you, do you
think that for some reason
maybe the history
of your country
the age of your country,
that liberals have been
able to remain liberal
without going completely
off the deep end?
Or is it maybe that your
Labor Party has just gotten
so bananas that it
allowed the liberals to
see it a little
quicker or something?
How about some of that?
- I should point out that the
Labor Party is in the process
of trying to de-bananafy
the first ever
usage of that word
- But they let
Corbyn back in right?
After two month smack
down or something
- Shorter, they allowed
him back into the party.
That's right.
They found that, although
he had been anti-Semitic
throughout his life, they
found that a small slap
for anti- Semitism
turned out to be fine.
So when people said never
again, what they meant was
suspend you from the
party for about a week,
which is good it's good to know
- But can you sort
of compare that
to what's happened with our
left and Democratic Party
and what's going on
with the Labor Party?
'Cause I think there's some
lesson to be learned there.
- Yes I mean our Labor
Party became unelectable
because it's nominated
the most unelectable
far left candidate to be
the leader of the party.
Totally shambolic, morally
and physically shambolic
and mentally shambolic
man called Jeremy Corbyn
lifelong history of crankery.
And you've got to think
of Bernie Saunders
without the charm
and with a good dose of
antisemitism thrown in
and you've got something
approximating Jeremy Corbyn
- Not a lot of charm with
Bernie, but I'll go with you.
- The point was delayed
(chuckles)
- Anyone's walking around going
that Bernie Sanders is
pretty charming, yeah
- But yeah. so they ran
really far to the left
and made himself
totally unelectable.
and as a result the
Conservatives won
an 80 seat majority
the election in December,
a majority they've
spent their time squandering
it seems to me ever since
but the Conservative Party in
the UK always lets you down.
And yes, but I think
there are some parallels.
I wouldn't say that
there's a greater sort
of degree of real
liberalism, true liberalism
in the great sense in the UK.
I think we have the same
problems that you have
in different doses.
We have the problem of
the media, particularly
left wing media, the
predominance of it
but we've got very
good conservative media
right-leaning media in the
UK from the broadsheets
to the tabloids.
Something I thought about
actually in the US I think I was
I was talking about
it with somebody.
I kind of heard
it was on my state
and they referred, I said,
in passing, I said, look, I
I write for every major
British newspaper.
And it's a great honor.
And I'm, you know, and they said
"do you think it would be the
same if you're in America?"
And I said, actually, I that's
an interesting question.
I don't know would be actually.
Because it seems to me
that something very wrong
has happened with your media
not just the broadcast media,
but the print media it's
I don't wanna get
stuck on it, but I mean
every country I know about
I know the New York Times and
can prove that it's lying.
So I can't read it
because any country
I don't know very
much about I wouldn't,
I would assume
that they're lying,
but I wouldn't know exactly how.
So you've got a very deep
deep problem in
your legacy media.
And obviously a lot of people
have been pointing that out
for a long time.
And I wonder now, if Trump
does go, those, those papers
and magazines will be
in want of an enemy.
And often as you know,
that's the worst thing
for a person is if
they lose their enemy.
But yes we don't have
that many problem
The problem we do all
have, it seems to me,
and you've written about this
as, you know about it as well
as anyone, is that people
have become very bad
at listening to a
contrary opinion.
And that is, I think
that's going to prove to
be a generational thing
that there just is.
I speak 24 hours after
the news came out of
Jordan Peterson's as
publishers in Canada,
that there've been wailing
and gnashing of teeth,
actual tears.
- Tears
At the staff meeting when some
some employees of
Penguin isn't it?
- Penguin Random House
Some of the employees
of penguin discovered
that they were gonna publish
another book next year
by a man who's actually earned
them their salaries and...
- Quite literally by the way .
He sold probably about 7
million copies last I heard.
So he floats in many ways,
the entire ability for them to
to choose all these
other books that
aren't going to
do quite as well.
- Yeah yeah.
It's only because of him that
they can publish the sort
of intersectional
fictional teen list.
Yeah, no but these people
we keep hearing from
who chase Bari Weiss
out the New York Times
who chase Suzanne Moore out
of the Guardian in the UK,
who cry when they learn that
a new Jordan Peterson book
is gonna be published
and pay their
salary the next year
this is a generational thing.
And I don't know
at this stage that we
can see it's completely
a political movement.
It's some kind of
counter revolution
that has been going on.
It believes as you know
that speech is harm
and harm is not harm
but silence is violence
and violence is fine.
It has a set of mantras.
And I simply think
it won't stop until
it hits the reality
of this life.
I don't know when
that'll happen.
I just hope it happens
very, very soon.
I think that everybody
who cried at the meeting
I said this this morning on
social media, everybody who
cried at the meeting and said
that they didn't want to be
at the publishing house
that published John Peterson
bang sacked out.
Next morning, your
job is advertised so
many smart young men and women
should be in the publishing
business and have a very,
very good reason to be so
and could be excellent in
their chosen profession.
And they're not because these
people who have no right to be
in a publishing house
are in it and clogging up
and making everyone stupider.
And so there's these
people that has to be felt.
We have to make sure that media
companies and others are not
held hostage by the
stupidest youngest
most ignorant people in the room
- But is the biggest problem
there that these companies
once they fall under the
spell, I mean, you wrote a book
about this, but once
they fall under the spell
they bring in the diversity
and inclusion department.
Their HR department is
teaching people to watch
out for white supremacism
and all of these things.
Thus, they destroy
their own entities.
I'm completely with you.
And, and I run businesses.
If I had employees
that were upset
with me over my decision-making
goodbye, goodbye, that's it.
You know but isn't that
the bigger problem that
once you've let this thing
in, in many ways, you're
you're the people,
you're the very people.
You let the bad guys in
and now they're in the
house running around.
And what can you do?
Well, what you can
do is to reassert
your rights as an adult.
What I see everywhere in America
in particular is the complete
retreat of the adults.
Let me give you an example.
I'm sure you've
heard many times.
I thankfully nobody
has actually said it
to my face or they'd
have it coming to them.
But I have heard a lot of
people told in recent years,
educate yourself.
Everybody who says, educate
yourself in my observation
is without exception,
the dumbest person I
have seen speaking.
They have no right to go around
being the stupidest person
in the room, telling everyone
else to educate themselves.
They don't mean
educate yourself.
They mean agree with me or else.
Well, here's a suggestion
the adults say, no, you
do not know anything.
You're 23.
You've got a totalistic
view of the universe
that you're gonna
discover quite soon
at some point in your
life is wildly wrong.
And you are making
yourself unemployable.
Here is your unemployment
form your jobs up
for advert tomorrow.
That's what the
adults have to do.
I'm fed up by the way.
So CEOs and heads of companies
and all sorts of things
but it's ever, since "The
Madness of Crowds" came out
I find they signed all up to me.
They whisper up to me
and tell me that this
is what they have.
And I'm fed up with the whispers
and the sidlers and
fed up with the adults.
The people at the
tops of their careers
all of whom are bowing down.
It's like that video that
went viral the other day
of this, you saw this
weird LGBTQ+ kiddy thing.
- Oh unbelievable yeah
the kid based yeah
- Yeah they're literally
they're bowing down
and worshiping the new god thing
which is the stupidest
person in the room.
And I'm not up for the
opportunity costs societly
that that involves.
And I think nobody
else should be either.
And I'm fed up of the grousing
and I'm fed up with
Conservatives grousing about it.
- But this is the stuff that
we've been talking about
for years.
So it is nice you and
I, and many other people
we write books about these
things, we can write columns.
We can do shows about
it and all of that stuff
and then we get what I
think you just said is
the most frustrating part,
which is people at companies
and %people in their own
private lives who are just
still simply afraid
to do anything.
So then they'll, Oh,
Douglas, I loved your book
but I don't want to
take a picture with you
or something like that.
Like you're still too
out there and too scary
that in many ways is the
most frustrating part
don't you think?
- Well, I think
that they usually
love the photo of it
may be anyway yeah no.
- No just don't wanna
post them on Facebook.
(chuckles)
- No what I find is that
they don't realize that
what they are bringing in is
mental and moral asbestos.
They don't realize
that it's toxic
to everyone in the atmosphere
who has to breathe it.
The job of the adults
is to strip the moral
and mental asbestos from the
building as fast as possible.
And if that means
stripping a whole load
of under thirties out
then fine, there are a lot
of very smart under 30s who
could fill those positions
and would do a great
and noble a job at it.
But it is absolutely incumbent
upon people, as you know
is what I argue in the manners
of crowds to understand
that that is what
we are dealing with.
Once you play the
diversity and equity game,
you are infusing the
lungs of your employees
with this asbestos and you
have to get it out now.
- Can I just say that
before we finish here
that you're in particularly
fine form today, Douglas Murray
I'm getting particular, I'm
getting particularly sharp
Douglas Murray.
Douglas Murray is
always sharp but
but we're really
getting it today.
- I am not always sharp.
- I wanna back up though
because look, I have
a Sharpie in my hand
and I actually scribbled
something down that you said
that I didn't want to lose it
because you said conservatives
always let you down.
And I'm in the midst
of, and I think a lot
of people feel that right now,
there's especially a feeling
amongst the Trump side of
things that, Oh, if he loses
I'm done with conservatives,
because we're just
going to get these sort
of limp-wristed people,
we'll get these Mitt
Romney types who will just
really sort of be
Democrats cloaked
as Republicans or
something like that.
But I'm watching "The
Crown" on Netflix right now.
And in the current season,
it is very heavily involved
with Margaret Thatcher.
And I just bought a
one of her biographies
because every word that comes
out of this woman's mouth in
this show seems right to me.
She talks about the cowardice.
She talks about
the establishment.
She talks about leaders who
must do unpopular things
and the rest of it.
I'm not even sure what
my question is there.
Other than Conservatives
will always let you down
that's what you said before
and you guys have your
own version of it,
but there are
occasionally leaders
that don't let you down, right?
At least for a certain
amount of time.
- Of course, of course,
the reason I say
I mean the Conservative
Party in the UK
lets us down repeatedly.
It's very bad at
defending its friends.
standing up for its own.
It tends to give up principles.
We've got one at the
moment where there's a sort
of awful feeling
that Boris Johnson
and the post COVID era
is going to basically
try to save the whale
and not much else
as if Conservatives were
anti the whales before,
as if we used to have
meetings in darkened rooms
discussing how the
oceans should be cleansed
of these magnificent creatures.
There's a sort of
let's do the thing.
People don't think conservatives
would do sort of thing
and that will persuade
them, we're good.
You then also have
that phenomenon.
You mentioned Mitt Romney.
You have that phenomenon
in America where
once the conservative
has been castrated
by the left, the
left pats on the back
The moment that at American
Republican becomes a eunuch
the left says how sexy they are.
You saw this never clearer
than with John McCain.
I remember when John
McCain was being described
as a reprehensible,
racist, bigoted,
old, war monger, much more.
I saw this with, goodness knows.
I mean we saw it with
Mitt Romney right.
- You see it with George
W. Bush now, because
- Stop with George W. Bush
- He's not Trump.
- And he's not Trump
I I fought quite
a lot of battles
in the George W.
Bush era explaining
that there were still some
things that were good America
and about America.
And I remember the wild
demonization of Bush.
And I'm just old
enough to remember some
of the wild demobilization
of Ronald Reagan.
Yes, that this is something
that happens to conservatives
and there is a tendency
then for the conservative
after the point of utility
or after the battle
to suddenly seek
some kind of sucker
from the enemy camp, Margaret
Thatcher never did that.
Never did that.
I've been watching,
I've watched "The Crown"
by the way, as well, by the way
its appalling anti monarchy.
It's so anti the queen
it's appallingly rude
and misleading against multiple
members of the Royal family.
And I actually think by the way
that it is really rather
Anti-Margaret Thatcher
they show her to be much more.
I mean, they show her
for instance, if she
didn't know how to behave
when she visits Balmoral
and much more, she was a
much more remarkable figure
than she has shown
to be in the series.
So I am delighted that you
think that she came across
as well in the series
because she was even better
- Well, for the record I'm
only about halfway this season.
And also at the same time
I've been following this
Margaret Thatcher account
on Twitter, where they
put up her actual clip.
So this isn't just
- Well, she was, she
was a remarkable figure.
I have all sorts of
criticisms as everybody does
of any politician but she
was a remarkable figure
and a product of
a quite remarkable
once in a generation figure.
By the way,
there's something important
about this, which is yes
she had a backbone because
she had it from a sense
of purpose and drive and moral
belief from the beginning.
But also to some extent
in the Charles Moore
biography brings this out.
She also found herself
into Thatcher-ness
as she was being Prime Minister
which is a very important thing
but people do grow into
jobs that they are in.
They learn by experience
just to some people give
in so others become
more resolute.
Margaret Thatcher was
a great example of that
by the way, at the end, she
was brought down by small men.
And some of those small men,
Michael Heseltine for instance
preening former politician
in the UK, keeps popping
up now to berate
the UK over Brexit.
He keeps popping up as if
he will ever be remembered
for anything other than a
spitting vicious latter era
where he attacked the British
people for their vote.
And for one other thing
which was getting Margaret
Thatcher out of power
and that is not a great
legacy, it seems to me
but there were these
small men all around her.
And I think, yes,
it was a tendency
in a British conservatism then
as it is an American
conservatism.
And it is to some extent
now to always try to
just do the easier thing
and what it meant always
what it means always
is that the left comes
up with a wildly
radical proposition
and the right decides
to meet them halfway
between the center
and the far left
and Margaret Thatcher
knew always, no
That is not what a
conservative does.
I would love to see
by the way, a change
around I'm fed up with
the as I said before
the waning and the
carping of conservatives
across the pond and in Britain
I'm fed up with people who
present themselves always
on the back foot, not least
because who would want to
join a movement that was
forever moaning about itself.
People like Margaret
Thatcher should remind people
of the nobility and the strength
of good right-wing
arguments, and they should
people should go to them as
a resource and an inspiration
to realize what true moral
leadership consists of.
- I sense that's probably
a little more difficult
although the right thing to do.
I sense it's a little more
difficult than just being liked
like that sort of, that's
sort of what happens,
that the conservative things
- She walked through fire,
she walked through
fire on everything
the economics, by the end of
her life of her first term.
It was not clear that that the
economics were going to turn
in her favor as they did, but
she knew that she was right
and she dragged the
country from a position
of serious trouble in the 1970s
into the country that she
left us when she left office.
- All right, Douglas, now
I'm gonna do the impossible
with you, which is, I think
I've done this with you once
or twice before at end
interviews actually,
but spin me the
version that makes 2021
a little better than
2020, a little saner.
Whether you believe it or not,
what's a map that
could kind of get us
to something that we could
all feel a little better about
or would be a little
less worrying relative
to all the things we've
talked about here.
Is there such a map?
- Well, all of us
hope, of course that
2021 is nothing like 2020.
My own views on 2020 have been
that we all have
one principal job
which is to not go insane.
That's not nothing the job
of not becoming deranged
by the way, little
anecdote, but everywhere
I went in America.
when I saw people who are
old friends sometimes,
sometimes new friends,
every dinner table I sat at
there was an explosion at
some point, it's not good.
It's not good.
It didn't use to be like that.
- I think we kept
ours to a minimum but
that might've been the gin.
- Actually I should have said
except for the evening
with Ruben I should say.
I think apart from, yes
maybe apart from that, I
just was as amazed by the way
in which what used to be
ordinary conversations
were just exploded.
And I think that's
because and I say this
at the end of "The Madness
of Crowds" as you know
which is that people have
over politicized their lives.
Politics is
exceptionally important.
And I take a great
interest in it as you do.
And I know how
much it does affect
and change the lives of
people, it's not a game.
That said it's a very
unwise thing to put
all of your personal stocking.
And I feel that a
younger generation
in particular has been misled
into thinking they
will find a purpose
and all the meaning of
life in political activism.
Politics always
lets you down just
like conservatives let you down.
They always let you down
politicians at some point.
And so it would be
a very unwise thing
on any estimation to put all
of your happiness
on a Senate race
or Congress or midterms
or presidential election.
Very important things
though these are.
I hope that people don't
whatever happened
in the coming weeks.
I hope they don't
turn off politics
but I hope that people get
a better estimation of them.
And I hope one thing above all
if I may say so for
the United States,
the United States
is an extraordinary
moment in its history
because it's clear that there
is a war on the American past.
And if that war is
successful in demoralizing
the American people
into thinking
not let's have a
reasonable estimation
of our past as any
country should, but
we were always awful.
If that succeeds, then
there's nothing good
that America can ever do
because it was always rotten.
I think there's a lot
of good that America has
done throughout her history.
I think there's an enormous
amount that America can do
for good in the years ahead.
But for that to happen,
there has to be some
better understanding
and reckoning with your
past because you are now
at the stage where
you could as a nation
be overtaken by the one country,
the one country whose GDP is
expected to rise this year
which is China.
I would submit to
anybody who doesn't
like the era of
American dominance
and there are things
to be said against it
as there are many things
to be said for it.
Just imagine the world
you would inherit
if this goes wrong.
If America goes the way
of Portland and Seattle and
other immiserated places
if it cannot find
pride in itself
if it loses its sense
of drive and purpose
and if the American people
fall for this negative
version of their history,
this is an incredibly
important access that the
world is currently turning on.
And as somebody on the
edges of the American empire
it matters as much to me
as it does to very many
of you at the very heart of it.
- Douglas there's nobody better.
Thanks for taking the time.
I know you're in
the midst of travels
and you got a lot going on.
We will link to "The
Madness of Crowds."
I'm sure everybody
has it already.
You're in second
print already, right?
- Updated edition.
Even better or right up to date.
Yeah.
- Nice.
- I'm likely way past
second parenting.
I mean, second edition.
- Second edition
There's some news
- up to date, new material,
new gags, new insults.
- It's all there.
All right thank you.
My friend, I look
forward to seeing you
whether it's on this
side of the pond
that side of the pond
we'll figure it out.
- I much look forward to it
Thank you Dave.
- Thanks Douglas
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics
watch our full episode
playlists, all right, over here
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.